I'm poppy oh hello what's your name
um Andrew Lewis you look like you make
electronic music well yeah I happen to
be a DJ yeah do they play your music on
the radio well not yet if you get on the
radio you'll be a lot more famous okay
well how do I do that I have to do is
keep doing what people like over and
over again that seems easy I know how to
copy and paste electronic DJ's copy and
paste better than anyone else on the
planet the only part of the song that
people care about is the drop so make a
job over and over again why didn't I
think of that because I'm poppy hey this
is really easy wow I can't wait until
I'm more famous like you poppy being
famous is really fun so everyone so guys
wait what forever you never get to come
back even though everybody tells you
that you get to live forever in heaven
can I leave now
shame is important because it validates
our existence please can I go home like
I really don't want to do this anymore
everybody wants to be remembered so some
people dress up as a cartoon character
in pursuit of likes and followers